Narrator: This is an early test video
for one of the White Spikes
from 2021's "The Tomorrow War."
But it's very different
from what the viewer sees
in the finished movie.
The creatures are not really conducive
to having an actor inside.
Narrator: To get here,
Spectral Motion built
a moving animatronic powered
by motors known as servos,
which was used as a reference
for the visual effects team
and even ended up in
some of the final shots.
Movement is what really sells
any animatronic character in a movie,
so roboticists like Mark
Setrakian work tirelessly
to nail down realistic motions,
like these gigantic troll hands
from 2013's "Hansel &
Gretel: Witch Hunters,"
which needed to move nimbly enough
to convincingly pick up
objects and throw punches.
The performer who played Edward the troll
wore two animatronic hands,
but they were so large
that the performer's hands
only reached the troll's wrists.
As he moved the hands around,
the subtle finger motions were created
with radio-controlled hobby servos,
like you'd find in a model plane.
Each hand had 10 servos
spread throughout the fingers.
Mark: Each finger actually
has two degrees of freedom.
That means that there's a
base knuckle, like this,
and then there's these
two phalanges here that can also move.
So you can map each
axis of these joysticks
to specific joints.
In this case, you're mapping
them to the finger joints.
So depending on how I map those,
you can optimize the hand
for doing different actions.
Narrator: Toggling one joystick
created a gesture or a point.
Running controls simultaneously
for the thumb and index fingers,
as seen in this early test video,
created a pinching motion used
to lift up the small object.
The work done on top of the
servos is equally important.
No matter how sophisticated
the radio controls,
the movements would feel off
if each muscle and joint
that made up a hand
wasn't in exactly the right place.
One motion Mark observed in his own hands:
compression in this area.
The upper palm had to line up
perfectly with the knuckles.
To achieve this, Mark worked
with Spectral Motion's
sculptors from the start
to make sure their model went
hand in hand with his servos.
Mark: The mechanical design
starts with the sculpture.
We can see these big wrinkly knuckles.
Let's put a little tension on there,
like it would be in real life.
So, that joint appears to be right here,
and anatomically,
that puts it right behind
this big fat pad right here.
So the anatomy really has
to be based on reality,
and that's where the best
mechanism designs start from.
Narrator: The ways in which the mechanics
and the outer layers work
together are even more important
when it comes to conveying
emotions in the face.
That's where soft mechanics come in.
These are cables embedded
in the outer layer of animatronics.
Soft mechanics are often
used for animatronics
that don't have traditional
bones and joints,
like the petals on the Demogorgon's head
that Mark operated for "Stranger Things"
or Edward the troll's tongue.
And in 2006's "Lady in the
Water," Mark and his team
wanted to give the wolflike
Scrunt an angry snarl.
Here are the Scrunt's hard mechanics.
This piece here both pulls the nose back
and lifts it up at the same time.
But those hard mechanics
had to work hand in hand
with the softer elements
of the wolf's face,
like these lips that pull
up and expose the fangs.
And it looks a little odd
here without the skin on,
but when the skin's on,
it looks very realistic.
Narrator: The skin itself
posed a problem, however.
Unlike a real wolf, the Scrunt
had a coat made of grass,
so one of the most
expressive parts of the face,
the eyebrows, weren't coming
through that thick layer.
They're like these two
points, and they move around,
and they have whiskers
sticking out of them.
Narrator: So Mark actually
strayed from reality
and based its eyebrows on human eyebrows.
Mark: It was necessary to
punch up that expression,
that there's no ambiguity about it,
when this thing is
snarling and it's angry,
that those brows are selling
that the creature is angry.
Narrator: When moving
down to the Scrunt's tail,
Mark encountered a very tricky
motion challenge: cascading.
These complex motions are used
for movements like wagging
or the curling of a tentacle.
So Mark linked up servos in
a chain, then created a delay
so each servo moved a little
bit after the one before it,
causing a chain reaction down the piece.
The more servos, the smoother the motion.
Mark first achieved this effect
when building Sammael's tentacle
mane in 2004's "Hellboy."
He realized that the cascading quality
could be retrofitted to the Scrunt's tail.
When the delay is set to
zero, the tail curls up.
Crank up the delay, and
it wags like a real tail.
The cascade controller
also works on fingers.
By distributing motion
from finger to finger,
Mark created the illusion
of finger drumming
on King Balor's hand
from 2008's "Hellboy II."
Despite their amazing range,
radio-controlled servos have their limits.
So, one of the things about robotics
that most people don't know
is that pound for pound,
robots have one-tenth the
strength of humans or animals.
Narrator: As you can see here,
the Scrunt can look side to side,
but it can't tilt its head,
because they couldn't fit the
servos needed in its neck.
Mark: Those servos are great,
but they're fairly simplistic
in the way they're controlled,
and they just do one thing.
You have to make some decisions
about what you're going to leave out.
Narrator: But fast-forward
to 2021's "The Tomorrow War."
This terrifying White Spike animatronic
that Mark helped create can tilt its head,
thanks to major
technological advancements.
The key here was a modern
digital industrial servo.
Unlike the large servos
used on the Scrunt,
Mark says these ones are
specifically designed
to fit inside of a robot without
sacrificing their strength.
This thing is ridiculously strong.
So we can put a big, heavy
head on the end of this thing,
and it can handle it.
I can command these with high precision,
which has really not been
possible prior to that.
Narrator: This six-axis module
has six degrees of freedom.
Mark: It can turn, it can
tilt, and it can also shift,
and it can change length,
too, which is very unusual.
Narrator: Like Edward and the Scrunt,
the White Spike is moved by joysticks.
This time, Mark used a
software system he built
called the Motion Synthesizer.
Mark: The functions are
represented by little boxes
with patch cords connecting them together.
So by connecting the nodes
together on patch cords,
it's really easy to
visualize what's happening
from top to bottom.
Narrator: While the module's tilt motion
looks rough at first, once
Mark adds filters to it,
it becomes smoother and
therefore more lifelike.
Take some of that filtering off,
and it can go much faster.
Mark: As I crank this up to around 60,
you can see the movement
of the puppet component
is now becoming very fluid.
Narrator: No matter how much more powerful
the technology gets, the finished product
is only as good as the
brains behind the operation.
You can always get the puppet working,
but you have to get it working
at the exact moment it's
supposed to be working.
Sometimes it doesn't
always work out that way,
so you got to adapt.